Ein menschheitstraum dinge einfach so verschwinden zu lassen unsichtbar zu machen so unglaublich jetzt klingt das ganze ist jetzt
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler aus kreta und wien gelungen und zwar mit einem ziemlich cleveren trick ihre tarnkappe arbeitet mit einer art
unsichtbar strahl und funktioniert in der theorie durch punktgenaue gegen strahlung wie genau diese tarnkappe
funktioniert jetzt in klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Die meisten von euch kennen sicher den tarnmantel
Aus den harry potter geschichten eigentlich zu schön um wahr zu sein
Einfach so verschwinden wenn man an einem ort ist wo man eigentlich nicht sein sollte klingt völlig abgefahren und nach science-fiction pur aber
nein tarnmantel und tarnkappen funktionieren zumindest
Im labor bisher allerdings in dem linsen ganz speziell angeordnet werden oder durch exotische
metamaterialien diese leiten das licht um ein objekt so dass es verschwunden scheint dastan material hat dabei eine spezielle struktur
Die kleiner als die wellenlänge des lichts ist seine strahlung wird dadurch
abgelenkt und verlässt haben kappe somit wieder
So als sei es nie mit dem objekt das getan werden soll in verbindung gekommen
Für den betrachter ist das objekt somit unsichtbar jetzt hat ein forschungsteam aus kreta und wien eine völlig neue
Tarnkappen technik entwickelt bei dem man weder spezielle linsen noch
Metamaterialien braucht das einzige was benötigt wird ist ein
zusätzlicher lichtstrahl nach angaben der wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler soll dieser mit einem ganz bestimmten wellenmuster das undurchsichtige
material bestrahlen, so dass es für einen zweiten lichtstrahl unsichtbar wird stefan rotter einer der beteiligten forscher von der tu wien
komplexe materialien wird wie etwa ein stück würfelzucker sind undurchsichtig
Weil die lichtwellen in ihnen unzählige male abgelenkt und gestreut werden das licht kann zwar eindringen und irgendwo wieder
herauskommt aber die lichtwelle kann sich nicht gradlinig durch das medium hindurch bewegen stattdessen wird sie chaotisch
In alle richtungen gestoppt und genau diese wellen streuung stellt
forschungsteams weltweit vor eine große aufgabe bislang konnten sie diese nur durch
metamaterialien überlisten oder aber durch objekte die selbst licht abstrahlen ein beispiel hierfür ein bildschirm erscheint aus einem bestimmten winkel
tatsächlich unsichtbar wenn er nach vorne genau das licht aussendet dass er auf seiner rückseite
absorbiert die wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
aus kreta hatten sich jetzt zum ziel gesetzt den lichtstrahl auf
Geraden und auf direktem weg durch das objekt hindurch zu leiten quasi so als
Sei es selbst gar nicht. Da die lösung für diese idee seine spezielle wellen technologie sagt der leiter der forschungsgruppe
constantino markus das wellenmuster gleicht die material brechung
ausstrahlt waren exakt das punktgenau muster der inneren
unregelmäßigkeiten auf das material so lässt sich die streuung praktisch ausschalten ein
senkrecht verlaufende lichtstrahl gelangt nur mit verlustfrei durch das material
Dabei ist eine sache entscheiden dem material muss punktgenau energie zugeführt werden an anderen stellen muss
absorption möglich sein heißt also von oben muss genau das richtige punkt muster auf das material bestrahlt werden dass zu den inneren
Unregelmäßigkeiten des materials passt denn dieses würde ansonsten
Nicht streuen doch so wird die streuung vermieden und ein lichtstrahl der dazu
senkrecht verläuft kann ungehindert und
verlustfrei durch das material gelangen und dieses konzept geht nicht nur bei licht strahlung auf sondern funktioniert auch bei anderen welpen zum beispiel
Wenn wichtig ist dabei nur dass jedes objekt mit einem
eigenen individuellen punkt muster bestrahlt wird eben mit dem das zu seiner
Mikroskopischen streuung in seinem inneren passt das forschungsteam aus kreta und wien hat praktischerweise gleich eine methode entwickelt mit der das jeweils passende
Punkt muster identifiziert werden kann in computersimulationen und modellen funktioniert die neue tarnkappe
Einwandfrei jetzt geht es in einem nächsten schritt darum das ganze technisch umzusetzen das projekt steht also noch
Am anfang hat aber absolut das potenzial in zukunft den bereich der planung zu revolutionieren wenn es soweit ist dann erfahrt ihr es natürlich hier
Wenn er dazu und auch zu allen anderen themen kein video verpassen wollt dann drückt mir hier ein aber aufs auge und vergessen ich den
Denn auf die glocke nur dann werdet ihr über die neuen videos informiert hier geht es weiter mit
Unsichtbar werden da geht es um eine weitere tarnkappen technik also nicht verpassen und draufklicken und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt